[Musique]
bonjour à vous bonjour louis-félix
chalon bonjour bonjour monsieur k oui je
vaux jour aussi à tous les auditeurs de
la martinique en particulier les parent
d'élève de la paix puisque vous êtes là
en tant que président de l'apec
martinique l'association des parents
d'élèves de l'enseignement public
pourquoi parce que la pète martinique va
organiser une réunion demain au lycée de
bellevue consacré à la réforme du
baccalauréat qui va se mettre en
application en 2021 donc l'année
prochaine voilà alors tout d'abord lui
félix lon première question tout à fait
ouverte
rappelez-nous ce que votre association
pense de cette réforme du baccalauréat
quel est votre avis général sur cette
réforme globale nouveau bac notamment la
pub donc à accompagner la réforme parce
que la paix comme beaucoup à comme le
pensait que le bac dans sa configuration
actuelle donc arriver à son but en fait
on était vraiment limite
les commandes et les conséquences du bac
actuelle c'était la difficulté pour les
jeunes de ce circuit dans une filière
permettre de déboucher directement sur
l'emploi difficulté de suivre les cursus
comment dire universités difficulté de
suivre aussi le clic et au sus de l'egc
école
donc il fallait réformer alors diffic
fallait réformer difficultés
d'orientation on va y revenir difficulté
aussi certains estimé que le bac
historique pour ainsi dire le bac
d'avant certains estimaient qu'il était
trop rigide qu'il faisait peser sur les
élèves trop grande pression fait
finalement avec les ce pas ce que
c'était que l'examen c'était le poids de
la note finale de l'examen qui comptait
on pouvait avoir fait une bonne année
scolaire pour une raison quelconque on
était moins bien au moment de l'examen
et puis boum l'année était foutue quoi
et donc voilà c'était ça aussi un petit
peu voilà dans la forme effectivement et
c'est vrai que le résultat de le
refléter pas forcément
là la commande et le niveau réel de
chaque élève
il fallait donc effectivement tenus aux
côtes de conduire de l'aptitude à un
élève de d'avant un travail continu
sociaux mais pas sous la halle et
messieurs plusieurs années et il fallait
aussi tenir compte aussi de comment dire
du niveau réel de chacun au-delà donc
d'une note obtenue à l'issue d'un examen
voilà alors et du coup c'est ce qui a
donné le baccalauréat 2021 qui repose à
la fois sur un contrôle continu et sur
des épreuves terminales donc en contrôle
continu tout au long de l'année scolaire
tout à fait mais c'est un mix quoi voilà
et ça vous ça vous va la pop alors ça
nous convient maintenant de la forme
après il ya la misère la mise en place
pour ce qui est de la mise en place va
l'on en parle dit à l'heure mais c'est
vrai que houleux le bas calculs et donc
qu'il est présenté il je pense qu'il le
qui posa le caractère un peu plus juste
voilà alors le contrôle continu va
compter donc pour le bac à venir pour
40% de la note finale tu peu comment ça
se présente cette affaire de contrôle
continu mélange et mixé avec les
épreuves terminales du bac à l'horaire
alors lille à la note de contrôle
continu va commencer donc on commence à
apprendre content de cette 2e continue
depuis la première donc on prend en
première et terminale il y aura donc des
épreuves qui seront passés donc là pour
rien voilà l'appel et prom anticipe ce
sont des icônes par rapport aux français
nous connaissions va l'arrêter ambitieux
de français mais mais en fait c'était
toujours une seule note alors que là
donc ils voient plusieurs une loi yens
aucune moyenne sur les deux années
voilà y compris l'épreuve de français
elle même est concerné par le contrôle
tout et pour tout le monde on compte les
marques les matières seront soumises à
ce côté ok alors
le ministère de l'éducation nationale et
le ministre jean michel blanquer
explique aussi qu'il a voulu avec cette
réforme du baccalauréat une école plus
inclusive et un diplôme plus équitable
vous voyez ça dans la réforme qui va
sera tout cas c'est ça qui est beau
chercher je sais que vous recherchez
maintenant est ce que c'est la panacée
peut-être pas on ne croit pas tout de
suite de toutes les manières comme
toutes les formes
aujourd'hui nous nous mettons en place
donc là là là c'est la première année la
première année où commando au cours de
laquelle les élèves de première eux ont
donc si ces épreuves de contrôle continu
après voilà l'année prochaine avec la la
la première comment dire ce sera
vraiment la première fois où ce bac sera
sera donc expérimenté bien entendu comme
toutes les formes
ce sera observée et des améliorations
seront reconstruits parce que il ya
quand même des réserves sur cette
affaire de contrôle continu alors on
précise quand même que chaque élève un
donc au bac général
on parle bien du baccalauréat général va
passer à partir de 2021 donc que cinq
épreuves à l'examen finalement avec
cette histoire de ce centre connu il y
aura quand même les les épreuves
terminales dont dont quatre dans l'année
de celui du français en première et
quatre en terminale mais certains disent
que le contrôle continu peut avoir un
effet négatif en ce sens que les
épreuves sont évalués un petit peu en
selon un programme et des critères
locaux
c'est plus est plus à l'échelle hoyé de
l'ensemble de la france national
standardisé en quelque sorte que ça peut
être un baccalauréat la carte en
fonction de chaque établissement alors
adapté au public 1 et ça pourrait donner
un bac qui n'aurait plus la même valeur
selon l'établissement où il a été
préparé au retour à celle non ce n'est
pas un bon ce n'est pas nous ce n'est
pas tout à fait cela c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que c'est pour lever tout
site où tous ces questionnements que
nous organisons justement cette fin
cette fameuse rencontre expliqué aux
parents en fait
pour ce qui concerne les épreuves de
contrôle continu il voit en ce qu'on
appelle entre guillemets une box une moc
de deux sujets l'orientation d'un voilà
voilà qu'elle dit prouvez seront puisés
voilà voilà
et en plus les véhicules et les églises
pour tenir les examens ne sont pas cool
j 10 octobre par le professeur de
l'élève ce qui donc avec cet anonymat ce
qui permet donc de rajouter encore
locales et kitty dans cette épreuve
voilà donc non je pense que en fait sans
vouloir diu dès aujourd'hui que si déjà
donc là qu'on a trouvé la solution si
pas ça mais nous avons avancé il ya
quand même une évolution et on ne peut
pas rester dans un système que tout le
monde jugé obsolète
il fallait avoir fait maintenant qu'on
qu'on avance il ce qu'il faut mais tracé
observé est améliorée alors je parlais
d'école inclusive un aspect aussi de ce
nouveau bac c'est que dans son esprit il
veut améliorer les modalités
d'aménagement de l'examen pour les
élèves qui sont en situation de handicap
et donc de ce point de vue là
effectivement un examen un peu plus
inclusif
vous êtes pencher là dessus vous avez
quelque chose à dire à propos de ça des
élèves en situation de handicap attend
que la façon de parents d'élèves donc je
suis à côté des parents d élèves qui ont
des difficultés et donc bien entendu
nous veillons en tout cas nous oeuvrons
pour que ses élèves soit comment dire
bénéficie de plusieurs change vraiment
optimal de façon à leur donner à 6,9 là
aussi peut-être pas autant de chance en
tout cas un maximum de chances pour que
eux aussi réussi ce le rôle
l'heureux le réclame et puis ici c'est
leur vie d'accord voilà alors on va on
va revenir à cette réunion de demain que
vous organisez
vous la pépin l'association des parents
d'élèves de l'enseignement public en
termes de martinique donc je le disais
ce sera à partir de 8h demain à
l'amphithéâtre du lycée de bellevue et
vous invitez donc non seulement les
parents d'élèves mais les élèves aussi
aussi les élèves parce que bon parce que
ça concerne la réforme du baccalauréat
exactement avec des intervenants du
rectorat et du lycée du lycée mais aussi
nous aurons donc en termes de ressources
sont aussi en visioconférence dix
représentants de deux fédérations
nationales de l'appep ce sont des gens
qui ont travaillé beaucoup beaucoup
travaillé sur cette réforme puisque un
produit que la pp temps en tant que
monde du coup c'est super l'éducation
nationale est en lien avec le ministère
et donc il a pu faire remonter des
propositions affirme t des propositions
ci pour donc le cadre de ses travaux
pour mettre un pas cette réforme
d'accord d'accord mais vous n'êtes pas
le porte parole quand même du ministère
absolument pas vont absolument pas
maintenant après que nous travaillons
2000 comme comme ce plan local nous
travaillons avec leur toile correcte
avec des chefs d'établissement nous
apportons notre pierre à l'édifice
mais quelquefois vous avez un regard
critique sur ça mais tout à fait mais le
premier à camors tous les parents
d'élèves et pour les élèves le ministère
voilà donc que ça va se passer demain
donc ces deux à partir de 8h mais c'est
toute la matinée c'est ça ouais on
pouvait voir la future arroseurs mai
2010 les gens une question n'ont pas
accompli prolonger peut-être jusqu'à
11h30 ou 12 heures lors l'objectif de
votre réunion que vous organisez demain
et d'apporter des éléments d'explication
parents d'élèves aux élèves donc sur la
mise en place de cette réforme du
baccalauréat est donc le nouveau bac qui
va s'appliquer en 2021 choix des options
notation déroulement des épreuves et
cetera dernière question louis-félix
chalon à propos de cette affaire de
transport pour les élèves vous savez
qu'une spécialité qui doivent aller dans
un autre lycée pour suivre cet
enseignement ça c'est ça fait partie
aussi de des nouvelles dispositions
voilà alors il y avait des problèmes de
transport il ya eu des réunions avec la
ctm et communautés scolaires et
associations de parents d'élèves dont
vous et puis le président de la fcpe se
satisfait d'une solution qui a été
trouvée
alors je sais pas si vous êtes d'accord
aussi avec ça
il propose que l'ensemble des enfin que
les trois principales associations de
parents d'élèves ump fcpe se retrouvent
début décembre dans les locaux de
martinique transport pour prolonger
cette affaire l'a dit nous quelques mots
en conclusion rapidement 30 secondes
voilà en fait celui ci a été portée pour
la fcpe
donc nous n'avons pas participé aux
travaux mais quoi qu'il en soit donc si
l'axé puis elle nous invite à une union
quoi nous nous irons a perdu au moins il
s'agit donc d'apporter une aide un
soutien aux parents d'élèves et aux
élèves nous sommes disponibles nous
sommes disposés à le faire merci louis
sélection d'avoir répondu à nos
questions bonne journée juste rapidement
signalé qu'à partir de lundi prochain sa
aux cadis va changer de formule ce sera
une spéciale municipal avec à raison de
deux par jour des interviews de cinq
minutes de chacun des candidats déclarés
voilà à l'heure actuelle ce sera fait
par alain livory et moi même voilà
bonheur des bourriques à 30 minutes
merci à vous voici la rédaction de
france info